i was watching a video earlier today the
one that we did at that little pump
concert where we dressed you up like a
little pump yeah video that was such a
sick video forgot about it we did really
good the on
the version of it that i posted on
concrete
the top comment is
guys do you or it was like d all caps do
you guys know this is tifu's biological
brother
do we know
the internet is so weird now yeah dude
like i got a bunch of comments on
america's got talent like that's tfu's
brother i'm like
oh my gosh
i don't know
that'll haunt you forever i'm the
trampoline guy
you know it's weird like that's one of
the craziest things about like meeting
people is like i like asking them what
video they saw or like what what they
like that i've done if somebody like
comes up and
says they like our stuff just the wide
range of [ __ ] that i've heard is crazy
really it's like
i'm proud of a lot of stuff and then
somebody will be like
ah
you know the time that you let your
friend on fire and then hit him in the
face with a water balloon and i'm like
holy [ __ ] like that's what you remember
you know it's just it's funny the
backyard at your dad's house is just
kind of like a a cesspool of just wild
crazy [ __ ] yeah always yep
i don't think that'll ever stop
hopefully we'll keep doing stuff there
forever it had and it was it had to have
been so crazy too like because there was
that one time that one point like three
years ago
when uh like you had the whole
trampoline video series just going off
and that was like the most popular thing
on the internet and then out of nowhere
your brother's social media just started
just like creeping up and creeping up
and just like skyrocketing out of
nowhere insane
yeah that trampoline versus was cool
because uh
the one thing that i'll always take out
of that is that we got number one most
subscribed channel for the day two days
in a row really yeah above pewdiepie
above every creator on the platform for
two days that was kind of like uh even
that wasn't even that long ago and it
was just like it seems like it was and
now people are ripping it off
there's another channel that does
the exact same thing that i did like
three or four years ago on his channel
and he's getting more views than i did
when i did it
and it's just dedicated to the
trampoline [ __ ] he i mean
he didn't credit me in anything so kind
of just took the idea and yeah made it
his own
there's a couple channels that actually
their channel was made off of the
trampoline versus series really yeah
that's pretty crazy
well imitation is the highest form of
flattery right yeah
what um
is it well i was gonna say it was like
that time when we were doing that it
seems like youtube was a completely
different place like a completely
different website back then you know it
was and it is it's yeah it's insane
especially like all that like now all it
is is just i feel like just people
it's just like
all it can be is a certain type of just
like [ __ ] content and so much of it
is curated and censored
yeah i used to uh
i mean i used to use youtube almost
every day from 2006 until like
you know currently you know
before i uploaded anything on youtube i
was watching stuff on youtube a lot you
know
and uh yeah it was like
you could just type in whatever you want
and like it would always feed you
something cool it seems like you guys
used ebon's world when you're heading
hell oh yeah
yeah i was like oh i was addicted to
that when i was like 13 or like 12 i
don't even know how young the prank
called voices the yeah
everything oh yeah all the sound boards
oh man
that was a wild time and like that was a
good sight is this still around yeah oh
yeah is it yeah check up on it oh yeah
there's definitely i haven't searched
that site in probably 15 years really i
still check up on it every night oh [ __ ]
remember world star hip-hop world star
i remember when though that was like a
thing that you wanted you would want
your video to get picked up by world
stuff you still do people a lot of
people still use it it's just
i don't know they just
i can't follow pages that post more than
five things a day
or else it's just like just seems
ridiculous
i don't even know how anything works
anymore like uh i miss when youtube
instagram and twitter all used to be
like chronological you know oh yeah
especially it's not like anymore no it's
not no i heard that instagram went back
to it no no i'll still be scrolling
through and i'll get a post from like
four days ago yeah next to a post that
was like a couple hours ago huh yeah
how often are you posting
i try
a couple times a week no matter what you
know no matter what i try to i've been
trying to post on instagram every day
everybody's making money on short form
content right now like getting budgets
for their reels or getting paid i don't
i just it's so hard i mean i i try to do
it because i see everyone else doing it
and i acknowledge that like if you're
not
if you get on your feet on instagram
you're going to see 15 videos and maybe
like two pictures you know it's all
reels it's just pushing reels to
everyone right now so when i see that
i'm like alright i'll post some reels
but
the real bummer is my hard drive with
like 36 terabytes of footage that has
like a good couple of years of really
good content on it just stopped working
so
right when i was about to just crank out
a bunch of a bunch of reels
that happened and uh
problem with reels is you have to
anything that's filmed like high quality
that's not um
you know
that's uh
horizontal you know and not vertical
it's gonna look like dog [ __ ] on a reel
like everything that i've filmed for the
last 13 years i have to crop in that's a
super like fish yeah it just looks
terrible
so you either have to create new content
for reals or you have to make your old
content look kind of shitty and it's
just like
i'm just hoping that this is just a
phase and that people get really bored
of short form content very quickly i've
been trying to upload on youtube a bunch
and it's been going well so
yeah it's like everybody's scrambling
just to adapt to whatever like the new
hot thing is like
if it's instagram reels or if it's tick
tocks or you got to be on tick tock oh
you got to do youtube shorts like
everyone's always everyone's always
telling me wherever i go like what i
have to be doing
yeah crazy people that have no talent
are becoming super famous too super fast
i think that that's a problem really
yeah like
i mean not no talent you know there's
some talent like
look at the demilios like honestly like
who was that the two tick tock sisters
you don't know who the demilios are
charlie and dixie dimelio
they're like awesome that's your
700 million followers on everything you
know
they're massive and i what they do
they dance they dance they definitely
dance oh i know who they are they got
they got offered their own reality show
too right yeah followers 130 million
jesus that's insane i uh i hosted a
panel for them at playlist live i was
the moderator of a panel before they
really blew up
i don't know it's just like i it
i see the most famous people on
platforms like tick tock and i'm like
this is not my place like i do not
belong here i make better content than
this if these are the top people on the
platform i don't want to be here what
about the island boys
what about them
they got [ __ ] so absurdly famous i
don't know that they did though i feel
like a lot of people were really just
making fun of them yeah like if they
show up in public they get booed
everywhere they go that's true
did you see them show up for that i'm
not envious of people like that at all
but they could slowly turn the tanker
because then they over a long period of
time they could slowly turn the ship to
where people are kind of laughing with
them in a couple years versus laughing
at them
they're just so unlikable you watch them
and they're so dumb too they should get
so offended yeah they just don't have
like the depth or like the
i don't know just
the life experience to have like an an
understanding of just
any a grasp on anything i don't know
they just
they got
you see them on the jake paul podcast
yeah or the logan paul podcast did he
try to fight one of the guys he just got
they just got said you know i'm thugging
right
yeah i just i can't get on board with
people like that i just don't you know i
don't hang out with people like that i
can't endorse people like that
you know i wish everyone the best i
think that that's very important part of
life especially the people that like
treat you the worst you know wish
everyone well but like i don't have to
condone that or
endorse that
[Laughter]
i